i want to know what you guys think will
and charlie about freeing
the software code of big tech companies
because i don't think
breaking these companies up or forcing
them to moderate in a certain way is
ethical
first of all i don't think breaking them
up is functional as we saw with
rockefeller standard oil at the end of
the 1800s we broke it up into six oil
companies he had stock in all six
became richer and more you know
influential than before if we did that
to facebook we'd have facebook prime
we'd have facebook messenger we'd have
instagram zuckerberg would own bits of
all of them he'd be even more
just as powerful if not more so i think
we need to force
free the software code and give other
people access to the ability to produce
that technology
and and then everyone can have their own
type of moderation methods like if you
want to say
no to a guy the gay couple that wants to
have the writing on their cake you can
do that on your social network but i
have access to that code so i can build
my own version of it
and allow that and then the market will
decide where people go
let's let's let's translate that into a
simple question of
what do you think the solution is i i
don't i don't think any trust
necessarily makes sense because
who wants to use bing right yeah any
trust in social media is a difficult one
because i think they're natural
monopolies right like people try and say
facebook and twitter and youtube are
meaningful competitors
um youtube i think is one place where
you can actually have meaningful
competition but facebook and twitter
it's very challenging because
twitter i mean i remember when twitter
was promoting parlor like they let
parlor trend they don't let things
they don't want to turn but they let
parlor trend and i think part of the
issue was
twitter knows we have all the
influencers we have all the journalists
we have all the rock stars we have
everybody uses twitter already and
that's an impermeable
impermeable mode that means that
competitors are trying to replicate what
we're doing they're not going to be able
to which is why
all the social media companies do
something really distinct all the big
ones
facebook instagram twitter snapchat uh
tick tock etc
and i think because they're so big okay
then then we're in regulation world
then we're in you know not you know we
need some de-platforming protections
non-discrimination rules
and i think it is tricky to balance the
need to moderate
awful content with the fact that we need
to make
these platforms open to make the first
amendment meaningful
um and so we want a world where they can
moderate the really crappy stuff
and completely and stay out of politics
and it's challenging to draw that up in
a way that
is first amendment compliant um but i
think it can be done because i think it
ultimately
you you think from a civil rights
perspective it's like you
we need to stop discrimination bases of
politics but what then just what if it
becomes okay for four-year-olds to twerk
we just i want to talk about the the the
florida law and we'll open up
into that so uh in florida we just saw
that uh rhonda santos's legislation to
protect people
was it was it was what was it was is
there an injunction on it or was
structured
right so it won't go into effect um and
and that shows some of the issues right
one of the things the florida law
did was it prohibited it would have
prohibited twitter from appending
uh its notices to tweets and the problem
with that kind of law is that's a prior
restraint right that's the government
saying to someone you are not allowed to
speak
and that's always going to be like
strict scrutiny
very hard to get through but one of the
things that that case did do is it said
there's a case called prune yard
shopping center v robin's a supreme
court case
um and in that case you know there was
essentially a california law that
allowed people to petition
in shopping malls to set up petition
booths or whatever the shopping mall
owner was like whoa
i don't want that that's a taking in my
property it's also a first amendment
violation because it's compelled speech
i don't want to associate myself
with these petitioners supreme court
said no
you're not the speaker you're there's no
first amendment violation if a state
wants to grant
someone a right to use your property to
speak if no one would associate with you
speak and there's no like editorial
component to it
um and the the court in florida was like
this is the path to if you wanted to
regulate these companies and allow
people to have a right to speak on them
you could that would be compliant
you just can't you can't do something
that forces
twitter to speak or associates them with
a speech or
uh prohibits them from like appending
their own speech and making their own
point of view heard
what's the texas has a different law and
we heard from alan bakari that texas law
is better
yes but uh yeah well let's get into that
what can be done i guess i mean what can
be done is
actually one of the things i've been
proposing for a long time you had a
private right of action
that says people have a right to be on
these platforms if they're wrongfully
censored for lawful speech
uh they can be have their accounts
restored but so then just lawful speech
is
always allowed i mean you could write
that law saying uh
writing a law that says you cannot kick
people off of a social media platform
for lawful speech that law would be
constitutional
under the under the reasoning of this
but they have the ability to blacklist
people shadow ban them do all these
things that aren't kicking them off but
you could essentially set their reach to
zero
or next to zero they could say oh you're
allowed to post but we will never show
your feeds and anyone
you're posting anyone's feed because
we're not obligated to i mean that's a
that's a
possible attempt to like weasel the way
around it although i think i mean that's
where you're still getting into
you're still discriminating a well a
well-written law uh i think the florida
law itself said
any form of suppression that puts
someone outside of the normal function
of the service
so like that's fairly obvious you can't
do that but
that could be part of the normal
function of the services things
judges are not robots the point as you
mentioned of prudence is that a judge is
going to hear and say get out of here
with that stupid
well you say legal speech right legal
speech i mean you can say
the things that aren't imminent threats
of violence but are very violent
and that's legal um social media doesn't
like that because it doesn't translate
in text the way it translates when you
say it to someone a lot of times
right there there will be legal
challenges where judges will say it's an
interesting point this may border on
something but if there's no what
criminal indictment
for a threat of violence or incitement
or anything like that then it's legal
speech isn't it
yeah and i mean maybe this allows them
to delete the content but it doesn't
allow them to de-platform the account or
something like that
right like maybe you know because that
then i mean
that that's actually closer in terms of
a question i mean it's
it like it again it's it's it's a really
difficult challenge to write a law that
fits but it's
i think it's doable and i think you know
there's a lot of tech people who are
like heart you know
loving the fact that i mean i've read a
big tech blog or the shill blog and they
were like ha ha
ronda sanders's law got thrown down and
i'm like i read the opinion
and it kind of does lay out a path for a
new law that would pass constitutional
muster yeah and i think the the idea of
the speech is part
of the problem the bigger problem of why
they have the ability to censor speech
is they have way too much economic power
and these companies are too big and
they're too diversified
and your point is a good one that
breaking them up can be very tricky you
can have the adverse
effect there is a way to do it and
rockefeller is not the best example
the railroad's the best example yes with
leland stanford and how we use the
sherman antitrust act
to actually be able to democratize the
use of railroads which basically allowed
us to have entry into the entire western
you know part of the united states
where leland stanford who stanford
university is named after built all the
railroads and became under huge scrutiny
by the trustbusters
of teddy teddy roosevelt's ilk and
howard taft defended him but by a
different point is that
there there's a there's a right way to
do this and a wrong way to do this
the right way to do this would be closer
the microsoft case is tricky in the 90s
it slowed down
microsoft internet explorer the the bad
way to do this
would be um i think it's bell is that is
that the right
the best the one they always yeah they
broke it up yeah and that one actually
didn't work
that one had the opposite effect but i
i'm of the opinion that until you
restrict
and that's a big word for a conservative
to use but i just don't care because
it's bad for our country
the economic domination that these
companies have
and so the best offensive move in my
opinion is ken paxton's lawsuit out of
texas
the google ad lawsuit it's really really
well written
and it goes to show how these ads are
actually disenfranchising certain small
businesses
and they're giving cert preferential
treatment to others it's what was this
like where they
they banned the pro-life ads yes but
it's even beyond that it's that how if
you know how to word certain google
adwords
tim's coffee shop is not going to get as
high of a preference as the starbucks
that's a really good lawsuit i mean that
story was crazy i remember when it was
like a pro-life organization tried
buying ads and they got told
you're violate you're violating our
rules it's like this this is
a scary uh a scary world where
people are just where big tech can
basically say
certain ideas have been removed from
society at the whims of mark zuckerberg
and only mark and that's really the
problem here though right is that the
censorship is one aspect we wouldn't be
complaining about this
if it was a sensor of like oh i own a
platform in
you know i don't know manhattan new york
and like i'm only going to allow
transgenders to perform in my theater
we'd complain about it and write an
article be like okay that's just one
theater right
the point is that this they have so much
power they've been able to create
through this kind of new world of being
able
in my opinion to have a very valuable
company around not really delivering in
my opinion
a correlated meaningful service with the
valuation of their company and what do i
mean by that is that
facebook is selling you they're a
massive data company that's what they
are
is that they figured out how to
individually mine you and sell back your
data
to the same 100 companies over and over
and over again
even if you don't use it yeah even if
you don't use it right and so apple is
similar but different they're actually
in the hardware business
and so this is something that i think
could go a very dangerous direction i
don't think nationalizing them is the
right case i don't think we need to turn
them into public utilities
but the argument that i hear is like
well charlie don't you want all this
innovation to stop from these tech
companies
like yeah kinda actually i do i think
that they're they're changing our
humanity way too quickly and i don't
think it's a good thing that everyone's
gonna be wearing oculus goggles in five
years in fact i'd love to slow down
their innovation
i want to preserve human beings and not
be cyborgs but you mean like the oculus
vr video games
or do you mean like neural link i i mean
like
how about eight hours a day on in
goggles instead in the real world
it's creepy man people play video games
too much too for sure i mean we're using
video games right now with these cameras
let me tell you i am i am deeply
offended by this by this story that came
out today
i was i was so offended i was like
flipping tables over and i was throwing
things
it said uh grilling sucks yes
it was trending on twitter yeah yeah it
was it was like your grill is filthy
the heating element is below the food so
the fat is dripping into it it's
starting fires
then you're putting your dirt your your
clean food onto the dirty pile
and i was like my grill has a heating
element off to the side
that pulls heat down it and then brings
a smoky flavor from the from the
mesquite chips that i can add to it
and it cooks my food very very quickly
all around the same time while i'm
outside in the sunshine with my friends
enjoying a nice day outside because you
don't want to sit inside all the time
so my point is when it comes to video
games
we need to be outside we gotta get that
vitamin d from the sunlight
but it seems like more and more yeah
they want it's like that black mirror
episode where they all live in the cubes
where the walls were tvs and they had
avatars in this in this in the
in the in the in the stands at the you
know american idol karaoke contests
it's and it's there's a it's it's very
huxlian in the sense of just trying to
pursue
immediate pleasure and not virtue people
mention 84
1984 a lot totally true i think we're
heading towards a brave new world a lot
quicker than we are in 1984.
and the tech companies are the they're
the main drivers of this
they think that they are going to create
this culture of pleasure
so you mentioned uh brave new world i
have not read it for my sins um what
about it makes you think that it's more
like a revenue world
so if i can talk a little bit about it
so aldous huxley was one of five kind of
dystopian thinkers that were
contemporaries churchill was one of them
um arthur kessler was one uh he wrote uh
darkness at noon which is one of the
best dystopian books all about the
soviet show trials
george orwell um and then c.s lewis who
kind of dabbled in this kind of
dystopian literature a little bit i'm a
big c.s lewis fan
so aldous huxley got a formal first from
oxford he was super smart
and he wrote brave new world which is
all kind of about
this idea of the over excesses of
commercial society
so they measure time as years after
henry ford so aldous huxley made a
provocative argument that the beginning
of the assembly line was the death of
humanity right
and so they they attributed positive
characteristics as saying
you're being very fordly they'd call it
fordliness and so in brave new world
uh there's this famous incantation right
that is repeated over and over again in
people's sleep that says everybody
belongs to everybody
and so and in this dystopian future you
walk around this thing called the soma
soma which is a pill that is not
addictive but gives you immediate and
total gratified pleasure
kind of similar to this and then the
work you go to work every day the work
is not hard it's not arduous
it's just enough to make you feel like
you did something even though you're
doing nothing and then during a very
plea
pre-planned hour there is unrestricted
group sex that happens every single
night
and so the whole overarch you're not
going to spoil the end of the book the
whole idea
is the death of the individual of
monogamy and this idea of the ultimate
value in huxley's world is pleasure
everything is about how you feel and
pursuing a dopamine rush
he may have got some of the details
wrong but he it's already happened
right and so the the where i think
huxley was not as
clairvoyant as orwell is i think huxley
underestimated the role of technology
yeah or orwell i think was kind of
creepily prophetic about telescreen
and this idea of double speak and new
speech double think and newspeak
and total continual monitoring and the
psychology of a tyrant
so if you kind of blend 84 and brave new
world we're living through this a lot of
different ways and i think the tech
companies
need to be crushed because they are
destroying our humanity and they're
trying to make people pursue pleasure
and not virtue
you know uh we're talking to ben stewart
he was on the show recently
and he was saying that it feels like
some powerful entity is constructing
itself through us
it's an interesting idea that it seems
like everything we're doing as you
mentioned destroys the individual
it's almost like whether it's un
intentional or not
the actions of humanity today are
dominoes being knocked over that will
create some kind of artificial
intelligence
and then ultimately result in us being
mindless drones or
eventually just dying out yeah and so
this is this idea of
the collectivization of society right
we're already
kind of succumbing to this of the three
terms i hate the most
which is experts extremism and public
health right so those three things are
always used as kind of conversation
stoppers
and the biggest one of course is public
health not personal health right no
but public health thanks for checking
out this clip from the tim cast irl
podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at
8pm where you can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you